now to this seller a celebrity attorney
Michael avenatti says he's innocent
after his arrest on criminal charges in
two states I am highly confident that
when all of the evidence is laid bare
that I will be fully exonerated and
justice will be done
federal prosecutors in California
accused avenatti yesterday of embezzling
more than 1 million dollars from a
client and defrauding a bank of more
than 4 million and federal prosecutors
on the other side of the country in New
York say they have phone calls proving
avenatti tried to extort millions of
dollars from nike according to their
complaint avenatti claimed one of his
clients had evidence that Nike was
involved in an illegal recruiting scheme
excuse me
prosecutors say he asked nike to pay him
and another attorney more than 22
million dollars to keep quiet sources
tell CBS News that second attorney is a
celebrity lawyer Mark Geragos he was not
charged and declined to comment on this
case avenatti has not entered a plea and
is due in court next month
if convicted of all the charges he could
spend the rest of his life in prison CBS
News legal analyst Ricky Kleeman is here
with a closer look at the charges Ricky
good morning I don't even know where to
begin on this because the US attorney
said yesterday this is a shakedown pure
and simple avenatti seems to be arguing
look I was acting on behalf of my client
how do you see it well it's one thing to
give jelous representation to a client
which is your duty as a lawyer it's
another thing to be looking for money
for yourself he was looking for 1.5
million dollars for the client who may
or may not have had a claim with merit
he was looking for twenty two point five
million dollars for himself and perhaps
for mr. Guerra goes and we know this
because we know this because you had
recordings that took place because he
was according to the US attorney trying
to shake down Nike through their lawyers
at Boyd Schiller and bois Schiller said
oh I'm not getting involved in this they
called the US attorney as soon as these
conversations began law enforcement then
recorded days of conversations and
meetings and the words are really really
wrong yes they
and aside from the criminal consequences
that he may face could he be disbarred
over this oh there's no question if he's
convicted of these crimes in New York or
in California he would likely go to
prison pay fine and lose his license to
practice law how do you think he'll try
and defend himself well he's going to
try and defend himself in two ways in
New York he's going to say look I'm a
great lawyer of course I'm a tough guy
you know I play hardball this is how I
work and I didn't do anything else than
any other client wouldn't have done that
fall is pretty short when you listen to
what the conversations are when you're
looking for twenty two point five
million dollars to conduct an internal
investigation of Nike and oh if you
don't have me conduct the investigation
pay me anyway
California is a different case
California is a different case in
California case I say he will not be
able to beat it's a paper case he
embezzled allegedly 1.6 million dollars
any phony dup tax returns to get a bank
loan for 4.2 no coinkidink that they
came on the same day do you think no
coincidence at all
so in legal terms he's in a lot of
trouble Ricky thank you